The Joe Rogan experience travel a mayor.
It's,
it's also weird like what we'll accept people dying from like a,
I was listening to this podcast where a,
this wolf lady,
she's a wolf biologist who was talking to my friend Steve Rinella on the
mediator podcast and she was talking about how we accept people getting killed
by mountain lions.
Yeah.
It happens.
It happened twice last year.
Right.
It happens.
It's not,
it's not really common,
but it happens.
But the moment that people start getting killed by wolves in America,
people are going to get furious.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause when they reintroduced wolves all the 1994 that's right.
Also that,
so that's a,
they're outraged that we did that too.
Yeah.
Well she was basically,
they were saying it was,
there was two really interesting things about the podcast,
have a lot of really interesting things,
but two that really stood out was one that the,
these people,
they reintroduced these animals in 1994 but there were already some wolves here.
Yeah.
And the wolves would have probably eventually made it down there.
Listen,
Yellowstone,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But that we aren't w because the fact that they brought him in and it wasn't
just a natural fixture.
We have this thing like,
oh,
so many ruined this.
Somebody fucked this up.
Yeah.
The other thing is that they number them instead of name them,
because if you name them,
it's like there's Dolores odd,
Dolores killed some sheep.
We're going to have to take her out and we can't kill that.
Doris.
Number three wolf one five seven,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's like inmates in prison and just give them numbers.
Exactly.
It's easier to kill him.
Easier to treat them like cattle.
Right.
So,
but we did the one guy killed that mountain lion.
They fought back.
Yeah.
That story turned out to be horseshit.
Oh,
is that right?
Yeah.
That the mountain lion was a kid.
It was a real kitten and had been separated from its mom.
The thing his mom got killed and it was really,
really small and really young,
so it wasn't like,
I mean he might attack,
who knows?
[inaudible] yeah.
Well he's still got a chance.
Yeah,
he's a bitch.
I don't know.
I'm just curious if he's listening right now.
I'm sorry bro.
But I think what happened,
you're alive and we're happy alive.
You better not touch wolves buddy.
I think it maybe was starving to death and it took a chance to try to kill him.
Yeah,
that's possible too.
But it was really small.
It's like 30 pounds,
which is still a 30 pound cat.
It's fucking terrifying.
I never saw pictures of the cat.
The one,
no,
I never saw it either because feel something at eight.
A lot of it by the time we'll,
okay.
Yeah.
So did he say how he did it?
Did he put it in like a choke hold or did he,
did he choked it?
Oh,
I stepped on it.
Something like that.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
I gonna ask if you saw this thing going around the Internet about this wolf pack
being tracked or there's actually six of my shit.
It's like a moving gif over time,
but oh yeah.
I have seen this.
It's amazing.
It shows how they never crossed territory's.
Oh,
cool.
Six different packs,
I think.
Yeah.
If they all established their territory,
the market territory,
and they respect our respect it.
Yeah.
That's like over Minnesota.
Minnesota has a shitload of woes apparently.
If it keeps going and it's a picture of Jimi Hendrix.
Wisconsin has a shit,
right?
If you pull back further.
Yeah.
Wisconsin is a shitload of wolves apparently like thousands.
Got It.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I could see that.
And it's a lot of,
you know,
the woods up there and just land.
Not,
not many major cities.
Milwaukee once,
I think I saw a wolf ones,
but it was,
you mean like in the wild?
Yeah,
it was big.
It was easy.
Either a coyote or was a wolf with,
I think that might've been a wolf because it was a just getting dusk and I was
in Alberta and I saw this thing run across the road.
I was like,
damn,
might have been a wolf.
Yeah.
But if you see a wolf,
that's the spooky thing is what are they doing?
They circling you,
checking you out.
And they're not usually a long right,
but those are the lone wolf.
But that's rare.
That's an asshole.
[inaudible] kicked out.
You ever seen this video?
This one's great.
No,
look at the size of this thing.
Comes out of the woods,
walks across the street.
Look at this.
This mother says,
oh that's a layer.
That's such a big wolf.
That's a bear.
No,
that's a wonder what the point is that it's a big ass wolf.
That's what that is.
That's probably 130 pound wolf or something.
Where is this?
If I had a guest can Russia.
Russia.
Yeah.
It's gotta be Russia.
That's a gigantic wolf.
Russia's had real legitimate problems with wolves were inside Bierria.
They have these super pacs.
They would get together like,
cause they were starving.
So you get like a hundred walls would form a super pac cause they could kind of
do whatever the fuck they wanted once I get that bag.
Yeah.
And they started killing horses.
Go on a horse stables to just,
it's a bunch of water ticked down a horse.
Easy.
Yeah.
But it's just the idea that the super pacs,
they realized it was too hard to,
to just take over shit.
All these pesky people in their guns at houses sort of got does fucking horses
now.